what's going on guys
stranger things on Netflix it's become
kind of a phenomenon people are talking
about what season two gonna be like how
about all that nostalgia and how come we
did not get more of bar but you know
what no one's talking about the science
of it so we called up our resident movie
science expert to see if you wanted to
talk a little TV science so dr. Clifford
V Johnson came on down and without
further ado I present the science of
stranger things the collective IQ in
this room just went up so many points I
am beyond thrilled to have back with us
our old friend he's been on the show
several times dr. Clifford V Johnson
physics professor at USC happy to be
here we normally talk movie science but
today we're venturing to the smaller
screen we're gonna be talking some TV
science stranger things I'd like to talk
about some of the science some of the
exploration in this show tell us about
parallel dimensions could something like
the upside-down world actually exist one
of the great things about that subject
matter is that we actually don't know
for sure if such things could really
exist and so it's a wonderful playground
for filmmakers storytellers etc so so I
can't go in and say oh they got exactly
this thing wrong about this parallel
dimension or what have you because we
you know we're still playing with the
idea but the overall idea that maybe
space and time as we know it have more
components that we have yet to discover
is something that people consider a
possibility the kids teacher explains
the other dimension and moving in the
other dimension to them like an acrobat
on a tightrope
the Acrobat representing humanity can
walk back and forth on this tightrope
but a flea can explore the other
dimensions by going back and forth
upside down underneath does that make
any sense at all that is something that
we in my field especially it's an
analogy we use a lot or something
similar often you know sometimes it's a
drinking straw or a garden hose or what
have you have you heard this specific
the Acrobat and the flea no and so kudos
to them for coming up with
new way of saying an old thing and
that's great okay the idea is an
important one while they're trying to
get across they didn't quite get into it
so let me unpack it a little Yves is
that you have that long direction of the
you know moving along the rope yes
that's kind of an obvious one so that
would be like one of our obvious spatial
dimensions that we can move in in our
world and then there is the additional
possibility of going around and that's
kind of a little direction you go in
because it's just the circumference of
the of the rope so the idea is that that
might be hidden because it's so small
you don't notice it so the flea notices
it but not the Acrobat because it's too
small
is there a parallel dimension where barb
got more screentime
what happened to barb spoiler alert she
got killed no one seemed upset about it
I thought barb got short shrift Oh barb
do you feel it possible that something
someone a being from another dimension
could find its way into our world here's
the thing one of the problems is how you
get back and forth from sort of our
world to each other hey exactly my
impression of it right yeah
the same question works the other way
which is how would we go to this other
world yes and as the teacher explains as
far as we understand it it would be very
difficult not impossible because what
you need to do is essentially modify how
space and time are currently configured
you would have to essentially rip a hole
in the fabric of space and time which is
extremely costly what's the difference
between one of those portals a wormhole
and a black hole black holes we know
exist in some form or other and various
forms out there in the universe
those are themselves severe
modifications of the fabric of space and
time caused by gravitational collapse
they require huge amounts of matter and
so on and so forth we can't do that sort
of thing on the problem with black holes
is that they're essentially one-way
doors hey listen can't buy a round-trip
ticket on a black hole am i right doc
pretty much or you come back in pieces
you come back as the fundamental
particles that make you up can you say
that like Arnold Schwarzenegger no you
come back in pieces ok we digress
if you ripped a hole in the fabric of
space and time would that cause a portal
they said something very nice at one
point they go we want to have a thing
that takes me from one place in the
university or the other on to another
universe and I go well that seems
implausible that you'd be able to do
that because it would require you know
the energy of several being you know
billions of stars right what is it right
good oh yeah but what if nature already
made them and it all we have to do is
find them and essentially they have a
little bit of that idea in the show
which is great there's the hint that
maybe those holes are ready they're just
a matter of finding them there was a
portal in the TV show one of which was
in a tree yes the one in the tree was
amusing could that be a real thing that
would not be anywhere like the first
page of my long list of places I would
look for a portal in the show energy
required to open a portal or cause a
portal to manifest really messed with
the magnetic fields around it would that
happen in real life that was a nice
piece of physics in there that is not
implausible and it would be a great way
of detecting them and they use that the
compasses it said that compasses were a
wiki way right Winona Ryder's character
Joyce communicated with her son through
Christmas lights does that have any
bearing on anything we know I connect
this to the magnetic field thing the
idea that what's going on is somewhat
tenuously connected to our world in the
sense that you can influence one world
through the other if you know what
you're doing or accidentally and one of
them is through the lights now light as
you know and electricity is an
electromagnetic phenomenon was not aware
of that and if connecting the two worlds
messes with magnetic fields then you can
see a connection there and I think
that's yes going so walking it back a
step not just the Christmas lights but
deal it messes with the electricity yeah
what's really going on is it electricity
is being messed with in a very local
sense what do you think of their
depiction of the parallel world let's
say you were the art director on this
show or a movie
what would you paint the parallel
universe like first of all you know in
all likelihood the physics there it
would be completely different from ours
which which unfortunately means that it
would just be bonkers yeah which isn't
very interesting yeah one of you writing
a good narrative so instead you go the
other way and you make it extremely
similar but yes and I like that so
another analogy people tend to use is
that you might have something like a lot
of pages in a book each page of the book
you know you can move around on that
page it's like moving around in our
world but then there's a neighboring
page and that page is right next to the
page that's our world so it's not very
far away in terms of real distances you
would travel it could be a fraction of a
millimeter oh but if you can't move in
that direction
you'd never know for all we know we
could be in a whole library of parallel
universes with every page of every book
in that library containing its own
universe yes did I just blow your mind
oh we think about some of the things all
the time but let's write okay right I
just had a very common thought no no no
no no they built a sensory deprivation
tank I love them with salt water in a
kiddie pool yes is that what you do more
times yes there was absolutely nothing
wrong with the scientific accuracy of
that I mean more or less the great thing
is the two reasons this is great one is
that they're doing a good scientific
thing which is they're trying to
reproduce conditions under which
something that had been done before
could be done again we need to build a
tank like the one she was in in the lab
and so because there's no internet what
do you do you call teacher which is
great you're in a romantic situation a
hot date movie night watching I believe
it was the thing that they were watching
a student calls you 10 p.m. on a
Saturday what do you do if I hear the
sort of passion and urgency in his voice
that the young kid had and he wanted a
piece of knowledge and I could give him
that piece of knowledge in that moment
you know he probably would he made a
good case you're a physics expert
explained to me the physics of Steve
Harrington's hair like had a do you
remember the 80s
was a Trier of extraordinary laws of
physics when connected to her yeah it
was the whole time and then you know so
much body right and then the shoulder
pads later on and stuff like that so
physics was being deeply explored in
interesting ways when it came to fashion
in those times on a scale of one to ten
how would you rate Mike wheelers dungeon
master skills ah yeah that's a great
question it seemed pretty good I mean he
really got into it he acted things out
and so on and so forth that was good I
don't think I had a Dungeon Master or
when I did dungeon mastering I don't
think I sort of did a full acting out of
the death of one of the characters or
things they encountered so that was that
was good bottom line as a physicist
how does stranger things fare as a
physicist who enjoys seeing storytellers
use physics ideas in a creative and
interesting way I think they did a good
job there's a lot of stuff in there
that's just made up and that's okay
because they think the foundation got
across some fun ideas that people are
now talking about and thinking about and
that's the purpose of art they set the
groundwork they sprinkled in some fun
physics ideas and then they worked with
it and they built and I think they were
more or less internally consistent and I
think that's good great that's a pass
dr. Clifford V Johnson I just want to
tell you if I'm ever trapped in the
upside-down world
I hope someone calls you to help rescue
me I'll do my best that's all I can ask
for thank you so much for being here
it's always a pleasure to have you sir
it's great to be here well that was fun
and educational what did you think of
stranger things have you been
experimented on by the Department of
Energy do you think dr. Clifford B
Johnson would answer his phone on a
Saturday night let us know in the
comments section we want to know I want
to thank you for watching screen junkies
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter
bye-bye
in a world where every Network spends
millions to get the attention of Emmy
voters the only way we knew how to build
high for our own amino
nation was to make fun of the TV shows
the voters work off wait wait wait go
back we got nominated for an Emmy like
an Emmy Emmy that's awesome
but wait then why are we making fun of
all their shows this is a terrible idea
you guys honest Emmys